and i'm just like right now i'm just
chilling out on like
my impulsive purchases but i did put on
my little list tonight
i will be ordering a red bandana and i
will be going to burger king and i will
be requesting a paper burger king crown
and i still think that many of us should
just
i think it would be the funniest idea
for a pfp ever is
everybody rocking the red bandana with
the burger king ground
but uh i was like oh there's no way i'm
gonna get those done today
uh well our pal beat us to the punch
here
uh here's trenton rubbing it in that he
uh he beat me at my own game
where's my oh hang on
my bed my bad kids
[Music]
i thought you said it couldn't be done
[Music]
shout out to murph you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
by the way i this [ __ ] killed me
this [ __ ] killed me uh when i saw
this after the show today
by the way that's the best ending ever
it just it cuts
right off perfectly you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
trenton wade quickly becoming one of my
favorite people he's
your [ __ ] lunatic
look at this this this just this frozen
image here is [ __ ]
it's just it's just insane this is
insanity
um but thank you for that trenton we
really appreciate it um
so he said the best promo he's done yet
now you know it's funny because somebody
actually asked me off the air timothy
uh shout out to timothy um he's a guy
that donates to the show sometimes and
i'll chat with him sometimes on twitter
and uh timothy actually
uh i guess he donated or something and
then he goes oh yeah you know check that
and he's like oh hey uh
i just wanted to ask like what the [ __ ]
is the what was the reference with the
burger king crown and the red bandanna
and i was like oh my god
like that video is like a gift that you
get to give people and i'm not playing
it on this show again i don't want to
get
i'm not going to push my luck uh but
anybody knows the burger king crown guy
with the red bandanna
so this guy timothy had no [ __ ] clue
what we were talking about today and i
was like you've never
seen this and then i sent him the video
of the the guy on the plane screaming
the n word over and over again and um
he literally all he wrote back was oh
gosh
he literally got not even oh god oh gosh
he was so he was like that was not what
i was expecting and i'm like oh yeah
that guy [ __ ]
that guy's a [ __ ] lunatic uh
burger king guy by the way shout out to
you hope he's not still trapped
in uh jamaica or wherever he was
screaming out the [ __ ]
screaming out those those racial
epidemics
in front of a whole plate full of black
people
oh good it was good [ __ ] so
um it was better than a two minute
keemstar end montage yeah well those
you know only really are funny when uh
when it's stupid baked alaska walking
around and you're just trying to get him
killed
which is fine